oi bom dia bom dia oi temos comigo ou
grande poliglota via amigo gabriel que
está viajando por mundo é encontrando
garotas lindas e falando em japonês em
coreano em todos os idiomas gabriel tudo
bem tudo bem sempre um prazer estar no
seu canal não quer
e é diga-me por favor agora quem quer ir
ou mais está sabendo presente momento eu
comecei aprender finlandês
o tema desse andré estou realizando um
pouco de polonês o meu polonês eu a às
vezes eu tenha chegado em a2 em promessa
é é ruim eu entendo adoro mais talvez
por causa do que eu falo russo eu acho
que meu rosto não eu cheguei ao b2 mas
eu também parei de praticar um pouco
então mano tá pior então eu decidi
talvez então eu vou tentar a melhorar um
pouco meu poloneses quem sabe chegar um
ter um e eu gosto muito gosto muito do
do polonês e e também pensei porque não
estourar um idioma totalmente diferente
que é o filme desses onde você dizer
nossa quantos idiomas fala e aquela mais
ou menos aqui então vamos ver o
português em inglês c2 que está muito
bem o que é bom
bom então eu disse achei que meu inglês
especialmente num é quase igual covardia
filho de contexto academia eu estudei
aqui foi eu fui para aí eu disse então
quer dizer eu acho que eu consigo me
expressar com mais confiança e até
elegância em inglês o que em português
uma pergunta espanhol se diz a expressão
em francês em francês a dizer imprimir
eu tenho lido em um livro ou português é
que se primeiro em vez de expressar
a dispensa palavras ymir seria um para
um limão para um suco espremer mas só
que não é desculpa então eu acho que daí
então por exemplo francês e alemão meu
eu com certeza cheguei no mínimo em p2 e
talvez em ser um e bastante quando neste
praticar ele vai cair no meu francês
agora tá bom porque eu venho praticando
bastante alemão não vem praticando mesmo
então deve ter cair no palco mas
italiano e holandês eu acho que eu
também já cheguei em b2 mas também mesma
coisa para ti como um meio raramente em
russo eu acho também que eu cheguei em
b2 a mandarem também heróis agora também
tem que praticar que todo esquecendo
todos africâner e catalão eu tenho um
nível bem alto de de compreensão e daí
vai cair de por exemplo um pouco de
romeno eu acho que talvez cheguei talvez
alguns é um ou menos
é bom mesma dois daí por exemplo um
pouco de um monte de idiomas no nível a1
checo eslovaco ucraniano até mas que se
bastante tá e assim japonês ao no máximo
eu tenho que um dia eu quero me dedicar
no monte aprender mas realmente não
falou muito vaso coreano introdutório e
vários idiomas que estudei um pouquinho
assim e que não for muito longe por
exemplo a peça eu acho que no máximo a
também mas eu quero quero aprender o que
limpa bastante gente aqui árabe também
só um pouquinho e tá aí é para eu
hebraico hebraico rosa e aí é uma coisa
que vale a pena a aprender apenas um
pouco
o que é sim tá bem se você fala mal é
nós o casou fala muito bem esse é que
iriam as mesmas bem outros pelo casa e
diomar que fala tem um tem para mim
gostar muito a embora quem não fala
muito bem dois questões dois perguntas
primeiro como como você faz para manter
essas línguas porque é me canso é muito
difícil eu por exemplo queria falar
maior em português pelo agora não estou
estudando pele se olhar bem se eu
gastaria mais tempo é o na semana o
messi escutando lendo o português e
agora é tem encontrado alguns podcast ou
globo do brasil muito
e agora antes da nossa conversa é tem
escutado a sobre a situação econômica
coronavírus se seleção né peço a pessoal
todo aí bolsonaro muito interessante
muito interessante esse é o jonathan
durante 12 semanas entre ao tempo para
estudar o português
e falar ei não melhor mas não é tente
escolher o que eu posso fazer
e o bem vou continuar seguir a aprender
novos idiomas ó vou molhar idiomas que
fala ou menos bem mas sempre uma questão
de tempo e como como você faz faz para
descobrir novos idiomas e manter um
certo nível em é nossa iremos suas
perguntas espetacular bom primeiro eu
tenho eu venho especialmente
recentemente me dedicando muito a a
oficina que eu tenho muitos alunos em
muitos países muitos brasileiros por
exemplo aprender inglês por mais e quer
dizer que eu venho me dedicando bastante
como professor desenvolvendo meus cursos
e tudo mais nem me dedicando até por
exemplo no youtube e eu tenho muitos
interesses prazer que eu adoro música
adoro esculpiram eu adoro desenhar então
eu venho dedicando um pouco menos de
tempo para línguas no geral mas ainda
bom então por exemplo eu tento sempre
tem uma certa exposição para idiomas que
eu já falo relativamente bem o que eu já
falei bem por exemplo eu tento tento ver
um vídeo hein holandeses às vezes eu vou
para o link e os tudo por exemplo eu
podia eu vou estudar um pouco de um
destino nem que tem um pau de criança
muito legal com ela faço ir eu esqueci o
nome dela e em holandês e daí por
exemplo também russo eu comecei a ler um
pouquinho do livro de púchkin que ele
tem um monte de livros de literatura
russa que eu adoro e por exemplo eu
assisto bastante vídeos em francês elas
actually que a cê tá vou fazer uma coisa
quer dizer eu sempre tento ter uma
exposição mínima por exemplo assim pelo
ter algum contato com as línguas que eu
já falo relativamente bem a tento fazer
isso pelo menos uma vez por semana para
para a maioria dos idiomas é um
e não dá para todos pois todos os dias
não gata eu seria possível
se você acha que é preciso manter uma
proporção entre a nova língua que estão
aprendendo e com os outros iriam mas que
já sobe que eu não sei magno sente a
necessidade de manter que que é isso a
proporção entre línguas novas e
manutenção manutenção manutenção por
exemplo eu acho que depende do meu
objetivo né vamos dizer assim se você
tiver um vamos dizer assim eu não sei se
vou fazer isso mas eu ficar bem sério eu
quero quero chegar o p1 promessas por
exemplo eu acho que eu não daí eu me
dedicaria vamos dizer que daí eu decido
aprender a ser uma vez um pouquinho
também daí o que eu faria geralmente eu
dedicaria oitenta por cento do meu tempo
de línguas para o polonês e apenas 20 a
última um deles um e até
um certo nível de progresso no começo e
daí talvez invertendo daí me dedicar
oitenta por cento nessa delícia de
porcento ao polonês para não perder e a
marca por exemplo agora que eu realmente
não tô com esse gol tamos lançamento
então específica de eu quero turbinar o
polonês eu quero tu vê lá as essa língua
eu venho mais ou menos assim dedicando a
oitenta por cento a a revisão e
manutenção dos idiomas que eu falo pra
ver se tentando um progredindo porque
logicamente acho que o processo tô
aprendendo ainda assim não chamei ele só
e vinte por cento idiomas novos como o
polonês e que não desse só vive uma vez
não só realmente assim comecei o básico
no básico então me concentrando bastante
idiomas que que eu já falo e agora vamos
assar
e vamos mudar mudar de tema é para as
pessoas que tornaria não
e fala muito bem o inglês não que querem
melhorar seu niver em inglês e
e você pode dar uma essa umas conselhos
não algumas ideias é porque é bom nós
nossa falam 10 15 idiomas não quero a
maioria dá para o das pessoas querem
fazer uma audiência breakthrough não é
porque aí muitas pessoas que estude na
idiomas inglês o outro e sempre tem a
impressão de não professar
e este que você pode dizer a nossa saúde
antes é brasileiros que têm dificuldades
com inglês querem melhorar seu nível em
inglês é você como o brasileiro é
brasileiro ou não brasileiro brasileiro
ok você é o primeiro eu acho que muito
do que eu vou dizer vai coincidir
exatamente com as suas recomendações é
porque exatamente o que basicamente que
eu sigo por exemplo a número um eu acho
que a exposição é essencial e
especialmente a texto e áudio que eu
gosto de fazer por exemplo de pênis
também do seu nível vamos dizer se você
estiver no nível bem básico talvez
encontre vídeos de ou que de áudio e
texto ou vídeo e texto de pequenas
conversas estão vezes 2 ou 3 minutos e
tem um alto nível de exposição discute
várias vezes tradução ver uma
vocabulário
e tem muita muita muita gente que gosta
de fazer fechado uai ele tem que estar
falar o mesmo tempo até gravar eu vi
depois e também por exemplo daí se você
tiver em nível mais alto realmente tem
exposição na material de qualidade que
você gosta por exemplo de que interessa
realmente pode ser um pouco caro pode
ser até netflix.com séries eu sei lá e
ter uma um nível bem alto disposição daí
pode ser assim talvez para quem tiver no
nível mais intermediário até o avançado
vamos ser podcasts ou até esse áudio o
sinditest 15 até 20 minutos e mergulhar
realmente um idioma se dedica bastante e
deixar o dele assim essa é a gramática
um pouco gelado porque tem muita gente
fica muito bitolada com a gramática e eu
acho que por exemplo é muito mais é tipo
de muita mais-valia
é a de por exemplo exemplos de alguma
coisa do que somente escutar uma
explicação da vez porque eu posso falar
assim ao o present perfect arrepender
quer dizer eu posso explicar a estrutura
gramatical ou posso te dar 30 exemplo
que você é muito mais uma vez peguei a
frases completas os empregando o prazer
ou é assim danúbia negócio a water block
que tem um monte de exemplos acostumar
ser através de muitas muitas exemplo se
você tem que acreditar no cérebro 10
provável a massa também o importante é
importante é prestar atenção por exemplo
agora estamos falando não para mim isso
na
dá para falar em português que eu não
fala nunca faz um cara mas também tem
que prestar atenção a o que você está
dizendo por exemplo eu dizia niver como
no espanhol pelo tem escutar ou não não
é nível 1 nível 2 nível aprendi uma
coisa que bom que nós nível essa nível e
acredito que a oportunidade a falar é
muito importante para falar para um para
que as palavras vocabulário passivo ó é
tão nessa eu vou abrir o vocabulário
ativo não quero também és uma o caixão
nossa estamos falando vai ser
interessante a para mim essa entre o que
você está dizendo não tenho também
prestar atenção a como você usa o língua
também exemplo foi aquela conversa não é
só alto também exemplo
e eu acho isso fantástico é muito
verdade e uma coisa também uma a gente
me ensinou outros vídeos é que
infelizmente muitos brasileiros
simplesmente tem medo
a falar inglês mesmo às vezes já estão
no nível bem ruim ou até dois aí no mas
ainda tem medo porque estão com medo de
errar estão cometendo não querem cometer
erros na frente dos outros e isso já
infelizmente só vai bloquear só vai
atrasar o processo porque quer dizer por
que não fazer um tem um amigo por skype
tentar bater um papo um amigo em inglês
mesmo cometendo erros mesmo e por isso
me lembra por exemplo de uma situação
que eu tive com uma quando eu tava
aprendendo italiano eu conheci uma
garota no mais lembro de cristiano.com
sem ter uma garota muito simpática e nós
italiano estava muito muito baixo também
e quer dizer para gente se comunicar era
frustrante até
e eu tava tentando tava ali no google
play isso não é de pouco em pouco
logicamente foi melhorando e ganhei
aquela confiança daí cheguei no
influência italiana depois de um ano que
sei lá e quer dizer não não tava na
minha zona de conforto aquilo que tava
em cima estava chato assim isso quer
dizer a gente liga ela tentando aprender
aprender inglês ou tentando aprender
italiano a gente nós dois apanhando mas
eventualmente de poker fogo melhorou e
fez diferença tipo de pouco em pouco
você não foi é o caso de tem que seguir
bom ok muito bem desculpa não é minha
vida por tudo que todo mundo poderia
muito bom sempre eh
e nada a ciência é assim é assim mesmo é
assim mesmo assim mesmo assim mesmo
assim mesmo ok muito obrigado um abraço
até logo e
e aí